I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Well, hello to you. You guys, we showed up today.
我是珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》（The Office），我们也是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来这档终极办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会深入探讨《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节以及大量VFF的故事。我们是办公室女郎6.0。你好。嗯，你好呀。各位，我们今天来的时候，
We had not spoken to one another this morning. We are both in black and white striped sweater things. We just- Look at us. I know. We dressed almost the same today. Should we talk about what we're doing today? Yes.
今天早上我们俩还没说过话呢。我们都穿着黑白条纹的毛衣类衣服。我们只是——看看我们。我懂。我们今天穿得几乎一模一样。我们该聊聊今天要做什么了吗？好的。
Well, you know, everyone, from time to time, we are going to be dipping into our dear office ladies mailbag and doing episodes based on your suggestions. Yeah, you heard us right. Your suggestions will become an episode. These episode suggestions can be office-related or not office-related, which brings us to today. To kick things off, we had our very own Cassie Jerkins make the first recommendation. Cassie, would you like to share with everyone what you wanted us to do an episode about? So I was in the office ladies mailbag
嗯，你知道的，各位，时不时地，我们会翻看亲爱的办公室女郎邮箱，并根据大家的建议来制作节目。没错，你没听错。你们的建议将变成一期节目。这些节目建议可以与办公室相关，也可以与办公室无关，这就引出了我们今天的节目。为了开个好头，我们请来了我们自己的卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）提出第一个建议。卡西，你想和大家分享一下你希望我们做一期什么主题的节目吗？所以我当时在看办公室女郎的邮箱，
and a lot of people were requesting Star Wars or like a fantasy movie breakdown. Yeah. So I was thinking like, okay, it's the start of December, it's the holiday season, so I think you all should break down one of the strangest things in the Star Wars universe, the Star Wars holiday special.
很多人都在请求星际大战（Star Wars）或者类似奇幻电影的盘点。对。所以我想，好吧，现在是十二月初，正值假期，所以我觉得你们应该盘点一下星际大战宇宙中最奇怪的事情之一——星际大战假日特别节目（Star Wars Holiday Special）。
Holy crap sticks. Where do we begin? I mean, I had never seen this before. I'd never heard of it. I just watched Star Wars for the first time last year. I had never seen it either. I had heard not so great things. When we were recording our second drink for this week,
天哪。我们从哪里开始呢？我的意思是，我以前从没看过这个。我甚至没听说过。我去年才第一次看星际大战。我以前也没看过。我听说过它不太好。当我们这周录制第二杯饮品时，
Sam insisted that it was quote unquote great, Sam. It is. It is really great. You know, we had to ask Ainsley to do an outline of this for us, and we felt like she needed to be here. Because Ainsley, what do you have to say? Well, I thought I was on drugs while I was watching it. I wasn't. Ainsle, when we got your outline and we started reading it, it was so funny.
萨姆（Sam）坚持说它“非常”好。萨姆，是的。它真的很棒。你知道，我们不得不请安斯利（Ainsley）为我们做一个大纲，我们觉得她需要来这里。因为安斯利，你有什么想说的？嗯，我边看边觉得自己嗑药了。我其实没有。安斯利，当我们拿到你的大纲并开始阅读时，它太搞笑了。
You were clearly so like, what the hell is this? Well, should we get into it, lady? We better. Here it is, the Star Wars Holiday Special 1978. This was a story by George Lucas. It was written by Bruce Filanch, Rod Warren, Pat Proffitt, and Leonard Rips with original songs by Mitzi and Kenny Welch and costumes by Bob Mackie. Fast fact number one is titled, What is this? number one is titled What is This? I don't know what it is. I don't know. The Star Wars holiday special was a television special originally broadcast by CBS on November 17th, 1978. That
你当时显然是一副“这到底是什么鬼”的样子。好吧，我们开始吧，女士们？我们最好开始。这就是：1978年的《星际大战假日特别节目》。这是乔治·卢卡斯（George Lucas）的一个故事。由布鲁斯·菲兰奇（Bruce Vilanch）、罗德·沃伦（Rod Warren）、帕特·普罗菲特（Pat Proft）和伦纳德·里普斯（Leonard Ripps）编剧，米齐和肯尼·韦尔奇（Mitzi and Kenny Welch）作词作曲，鲍勃·麦基（Bob Mackie）负责服装。趣味冷知识第一号，标题是：这是什么？第一号标题是：这是什么？我不知道这是什么。我不知道。星际大战假日特别节目是哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）于1978年11月17日首播的电视特别节目。那
was the weekend before Thanksgiving. This was prime placement. Star Wars, the movie, had been released the year prior and had become the highest grossing movie in history as well as a cultural phenomenon. The sequel, The Empire Strikes Back, was still two years away. So George Lucas was convinced by people to do this Star Wars holiday television special as a way of keeping fans interested in the franchise. Yes, he has been quoted many times saying that he got talked into this. He wants you to know.
是感恩节前的周末。这是黄金档期。电影《星际大战》于前一年上映，并成为历史上票房最高的电影，也是一种文化现象。它的续集《帝国反击战》（The Empire Strikes Back）还要两年才会上映。因此，乔治·卢卡斯被大家说服制作了这个星际大战假日电视特别节目，以此来保持粉丝对这个系列的兴趣。是的，他曾多次在采访中说他是被说服才接下这个的。他很想让你们知道这一点。
Yeah. But they said we could sell more toys this holiday season. And maybe, this was one of their pitches, maybe we could make some new fans who didn't see Star Wars in theaters. Yeah, there's like three of them left. Maybe they'll get on board. Everyone had seen this movie at this time, except for you.
对。但他们说，我们可以在这个假日季卖出更多的玩具。也许——这是他们的推销词之一——也许我们可以吸引一些没有在电影院看过星际大战的新粉丝。对，那种人大概只剩三个了吧。也许他们会加入进来。那时候所有人都看过这部电影，除了你。
Except for me. This was for you, Jenna. this time, except for you. Except for me. This was for you, Jenna. This holiday special was for you. Oh, boy. Well, wow. This movie special stars the main cast of the original Star Wars. Everyone has a cameo.
除了我。这是给你的，珍娜。那时候所有人都看过这部电影，除了你。除了我。这是给你的，珍娜。这个假日节目就是为你准备的。哦，天哪。好吧，哇。这部电影特辑由原版星际大战的主演阵容主演。每个人都有客串。
Yes. And like traditional holiday specials of the time it is a type of variety show so it has cameos by comedic actors it has musical numbers. Angela take us back to 1978 when this special aired you you said you wanted to I just want to talk a little bit about it. I just wanted to get you in the mood for 1978. Okay. First of all the best-selling album of 1978 was Saturday Night Fever, the soundtrack by the Bee Gees. It spent 24 weeks at number one on the Billboard 200. 24 weeks! That's a long time. I think we need to hear it to set the mood. Okay. Uh-huh. Where are my roller skates? Come on. So this is what people were grooving out to.
是的。而且就像当时的传统节日特辑一样，它是一种综艺节目，所以它有喜剧演员的客串，还有音乐表演。安吉拉，带我们回到1978年这个特辑播出的那一刻吧，你之前说你想——我只是想多谈谈它。我只是想让你感受一下1978年的气氛。好吧。首先，1978年最畅销的专辑是《周六夜狂热》（Saturday Night Fever），比吉斯乐队（Bee Gees）的原声带。它在公告牌二百强专辑榜（Billboard 200）上连续24周排名第一。24周！那可真是一段很长的时间。我想我们需要听听它来感受一下气氛。好的。呃哼。我的溜冰鞋在哪里？来吧。所以这就是当时人们伴随着摇摆的音乐。
Uh-huh. Are you feeling it? Are you feeling 1978? I'm feeling it. Yeah. All right. I can feel my landline phone in my hand. How happy are you? I love it. I'm feeling my roller skates. Okay. And you might be curious what the most popular toys were. I'm gonna give you the top three. The first one, you guessed it, were the Star Wars figurines that came out. Now they came out in 1977. The toy manufacturer Kenner ran out of them almost immediately. They had to give out certificates. Like you could pay $9 and you got like a piece of cardboard that you could then mail into the manufacturer and then they would, when they finally got back in stock, mail you a figurine. Wow. They were called the early bird
呃哼。你有这种感觉吗？你有1978年的感觉吗？我有这种感觉。耶。好吧。我能感觉到我的座机话筒拿在手里。你有多开心？我太喜欢了。我能感觉到我的溜冰鞋。好的。你可能对最受欢迎的玩具感到好奇。我要告诉你前三名。第一个，你猜对了，就是刚推出的星际大战手办。它们是1977年推出的。玩具制造商肯纳（Kenner）几乎立刻就卖光了。他们不得不发放凭证。比如你付9美元，就能得到一张硬纸板，然后你可以把它寄给制造商，等他们终于有库存时，就会给你寄一个手办。哇。它们被称为早鸟
figurines. They now go for thousands of dollars. For example, the 1978 Luke Skywalker Early Bird 12A figurine is a huge ticket item, but guess which one has sold for the most? It set a world's most valuable toy record. I actually weirdly think I know this because I feel like Mark Hamill did an interview about it once. Is it a Luke Skywalker something? No. I thought there was like some batch of him that was made incorrectly and someone has one. Well those always go for a lot and you're on the right track here but the extremely rare Star Wars action figure that sold for $525,000 half a million dollars for a little figurine, was a hand-painted
手办。现在它们价值数千美元。例如，1978年的卢克·天行者（Luke Skywalker）早鸟12A手办是一个极其抢手的藏品，但你猜哪一个卖得最贵？它创下了世界上最贵玩具的纪录。不知为何，我觉得我知道这个，因为我觉得马克·哈米尔（Mark Hamill）曾经为此接受过采访。是卢克·天行者的某种手办吗？不是。我以为有一批是做错了，然后有人收藏了一个。嗯，那些价格总是很高，你的方向大致是对的，但那个极为罕见的星际大战动作玩偶售价高达52.5万美元——半百万美元买一个小玩偶——它是一个手绘的
missile firing model of the bounty hunter Boba Fett. Oh yeah, it was never released to the public because it was deemed a choking hazard in the 1970s. The toy, one of only two still in existence, beat all other of the world's priciest toy. This is the one everyone wanted. I thought it was pretty crazy. It features a rocket firing backpack. It's not available in stores and it's a hot commodity. Wow.
导弹发射模型，原型是赏金猎人波巴·费特（Boba Fett）。哦，对，它从未向公众发售，因为它在20世纪70年代被认为有窒息危险。这个玩具是现存仅有的两个之一，打破了其他所有世界上最贵的玩具纪录。这就是每个人都想要的那个。我觉得这挺疯狂的。它配有一个发射火箭的背包。它在商店里买不到，是个抢手货。哇。
But don't choke on it. I guess you could possibly choke on it. It would be a real shame to spend like $500,000 on something and then choke on it. Really bad. Yeah. The other two top seller toys at the time were Hungry Hungry Hippos. Had it. Had it. I think we still have it. Also maybe a choking hazard. Also maybe. And a pogo stick. Tried one. Painful. Had it. Painful. Toys were very mean to you back in the 70s. They posed a lot of hazards. Is this when the lawn darts came out as well? Feels like maybe. Lawn dart time. Okay. Well thank you for that Angela. I feel like I'm in 1978. Yeah.
但别把它吞下去了。我想你确实可能会被它噎住。花50万美元买个东西然后被它噎住，那就太遗憾了。真的很糟糕。对。当时另外两个畅销玩具是“饿饿河马”（Hungry Hungry Hippos）。我有。我有。我觉得我们现在还留着。可能也有窒息危险。可能也有。还有高跷。试过一次。很痛。我有。很痛。70年代的玩具对你们可真不好。它们有很多危险隐患。镖靶（lawn darts）也是在这个时候出来的吗？感觉好像是吧。掷镖靶的时代。好吧。谢谢你，安吉拉。我觉得我真的身处1978年了。耶。
Are you ready for Fast Fact number two? Yes. I titled this one, This Was a Sh** Show from the Beginning. I found an amazing Vanity Fair article from 2008. They did a whole write-up on this movie. It was like a look back. They interviewed a bunch of people from the article and writer Bruce Philanch said that it was George Lucas's intent on building the Star Wars holiday special around the family of Chewbacca and Life Day. That is the Wookie equivalent of like Christmas. Yeah, big holiday. Bruce Philanch said the writers really struggled, which I think is clear if you
你准备好听趣味冷知识第二号了吗？准备好了。我给这个起名叫：这从一开始就是个烂摊子（Sh** Show）。我找到了一篇2008年《名利场》（Vanity Fair）的精彩文章。他们对这部电影做了一个全面的报道。就像是一次回顾。他们采访了文章中的许多人，编剧布鲁斯·菲兰奇说，乔治·卢卡斯的本意是围绕着丘巴卡（Chewbacca）的家人和生命日（Life Day）来构建星际大战假日特别节目的。那是伍基人（Wookiee）相当于圣诞节的节日。对，重大节日。布鲁斯·菲兰奇说编剧们非常挣扎，我觉得如果你
watch it. By the dialogue? By the whole thing. They also went through two different directors on this project. Oh no, that's never a good sign. No, first there was David Acamba. He was around for all of the pre-production, but he only shot a handful of segments, most notably the one starring Bea Arthur
看了就会很清楚。是因为对白吗？因为整部作品。他们在这个项目上还换了两个不同的导演。哦不，这可绝不是个好兆头。对，首先是大卫·阿坎巴（David Acomba）。他参与了所有的前期制作，但他只拍摄了一小部分镜头，其中最著名的是由Bea Arthur主演的镜头，
and also the Jefferson Starship musical number. They brought in Steve Bender mid shoot to take over directing and Bender's only contact with George Lucas was that they gave him a Wookie Bible. Oh, like our show Bible. And it was a brochure that was a backstory of the entire Chewbacca family. But if he had a question outside of that Chewbacca Bible, Lucas was like not available, not taking a phone call. He was not super available from my research. Got it.
还有杰斐逊星船（Jefferson Starship）的音乐表演。他们在拍摄中途找来了史蒂夫·本德（Steve Bender）接替导演工作，而本德与乔治·卢卡斯唯一的接触就是他们给了他一本伍基圣经。哦，就像我们的节目圣经一样。那是一本小册子，里面记载了整个丘巴卡家族的背景故事。但如果他在那本伍基圣经之外还有什么疑问，卢卡斯基本上就是“不可用”，不接电话。根据我的研究，他并不是特别容易联系到。明白了。
Steve Bender's primary job was to try to bring this production, which was over budget and behind schedule, to a close. He also had to shoot the scenes that involved the members of the original cast. There was Mark Hamill, Harrison Ford, Carrie Fisher, and Peter Mayhew who played Chewbacca. Guess what? None of them wanted to be in the special. They all had to be begged to participate. I read that too. Mark Hamill was asked about the holiday special at a fan convention,
史蒂夫·本德的主要工作是试图收尾这部超支且落后于进度的制作。他还必须拍摄涉及原版演员阵容的场景。有马克·哈米尔、哈里森·福特（Harrison Ford）、凯丽·费雪（Carrie Fisher）和饰演丘巴卡的彼得·梅休（Peter Mayhew）。你猜怎么着？他们没有一个人想出演这个特辑。他们全都是被苦苦哀求才参与的。我也读到过这个。马克·哈米尔在一次粉丝见面会上被问及这个假日特辑时，
and he said he didn't want to do it but George Lucas convinced him to do it to help sell toys. And you might know that Mark Hamill famously negotiated a very good deal on merchandise and he made so much effing money on merchandise. Well I have read that Mark Hamill's deal with Star Wars, because he made so much money, that now studios, they took note. And all these big action movies like Marvel and where they have action figures, actors don't get the same deal because Mark Hamill kind of broke it.
他说他不想演，但乔治·卢卡斯说服了他，为了帮忙卖玩具。你可能知道，马克·哈米尔因谈判争取到了非常优厚的商品分成协议而闻名，他在商品上赚了特么大笔的钱。嗯，我读到过马克·哈米尔与星际大战的协议，因为他赚了那么多钱，现在各大电影公司都引以为戒了。所有这些像漫威这样拥有手办的大制作动作电影，演员们都拿不到同样的协议了，因为马克·哈米尔某种程度上打破了这个惯例。
No. I mean, listen, we know that with The Office. We are everywhere on calendars and mugs and sweaters and all that sort of stuff. We don't see money from that. What do we get? I think in 2018, I got a check for $700 for all that merchandise, something like that. Yeah, like eight years ago, I think I got a check for 173 bucks. Yeah, my face is on a shot glass. Right, right. Thanks, Mark Hamill. Yeah. My face is on a shot glass. Right. Right. Thanks, Mark Hamill.
不会吧。我的意思是，听着，我们对《办公室》也很清楚这一点。我们无处不在——日历、马克杯、毛衣以及各种各样的东西。我们可没从那些上面看到钱。我们得到了什么？我想在2018年，我为所有那些周边商品收到了700美元的支票，差不多就是这样。对，大概八年前，我想我收到了一张173美元的支票。对，我的脸印在一个小酒杯上。对，对。谢谢你，马克·哈米尔。对，我的脸印在一个小酒杯上。对。对。谢谢你，马克·哈米尔。
But Mark Hamill, good for you, buddy. Good for you. Yeah. Well, I don't know if it helps sell more toys, but that's why Mark Hamill did it. Harrison Ford was especially reluctant to do it. Remember when Alison Jones was on the podcast and she talked about how, like, to a film star doing TV, especially TV comedy was kind of bottom of the barrel. Yeah. I mean, these were the biggest film stars. They were in the highest grossing movie of all time.
不过马克·哈米尔，真为你高兴，老兄。真为你高兴。好吧，我不知道这有没有帮忙卖出更多玩具，但这就是马克·哈米尔参演的原因。哈里森·福特尤其不愿意演。还记得艾莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones）上播客时谈到过吗，对于一个电影明星来说，拍电视剧，尤其是电视剧喜剧，简直就是底层中的底层。对。我的意思是，这些可是最大牌的电影明星。他们出演了有史以来票房最高的电影。
I watched Harrison Ford on Conan O'Brien. I did too. Did you when he asked him about it? He was like, what about this Star Wars Christmas special? And he was just kept shaking his head. And then he said, it doesn't exist. And Conan was like, I do have a tape. And then Harrison Ford pretended to strangle Conan.
我看过哈里森·福特上柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）的节目。我也看过。当柯南问他这件事时，你看到了吗？他说，星际大战圣诞节特辑是怎么回事？他当时一直在摇头。然后他说，这根本不存在。柯南就说，我确实有一盘录像带。然后哈里森·福特就假装要掐死柯南。
Yes. Carrie Fisher said she would do it, but only if she got to sing. And she did. All right, time for Fast Fact number three. I'm calling this one, how was it received? How did people respond? How did it go over?
对。凯丽·费雪说她愿意演，但前提是她得能唱歌。她确实唱了。好吧，是时候听趣味冷知识第三号了。我把这个叫做：反响如何？人们是怎么回应的？效果怎么样？
Well, it was seen by close to 13 million television households. That seems like a lot. But it finished second. ABC's Love Boat and the ABC miniseries Pearl beat it. Hmm. I did love Love Boat. Yeah, you might have watched Love Boat instead. Here are some things that critics have said over the years about the special.
嗯，有将近1300万个电视家庭观看了它。这听起来好像很多。但它只排在第二位。ABC的《爱之船》（Love Boat）和ABC迷你剧《珍珠港》（Pearl）击败了它。嗯。我确实很喜欢《爱之船》。对，你当时可能去看《爱之船》了。以下是多年来评论家们对这个特辑的一些评价：
David Hofstede, author of What Were They Thinking? The 100 Dumbest Events in Television History, ranked the Star Wars Holiday Special as number one, calling it, quote, the worst two hours of television ever. Oh, Alex Carter from Den of Greek said, quote, words have not been invented to describe how bad it is. Alan French from Sunshine State Cineplex wrote, quote, you will curse God for this shows near existence.
大卫·霍夫斯特德（David Hofstede），《他们在想什么？电视史上最愚蠢的100个事件》（What Were They Thinking? The 100 Dumbest Events in Television History）一书的作者，将《星际大战假日特别节目》列为第一名，称其为“电视史上最糟糕的两小时”。哦，来自Den of Geek的亚历克斯·卡特（Alex Carter）说：“人类还没有发明出足够的词汇来形容它有多糟糕。”Sunshine State Cineplex的艾伦·弗兰奇（Alan French）写道：“你会为这个节目的险些存在而诅咒上帝。”
Like we said, the cast hates it. They barely speak of it. Carrie Fisher revealed that she asked for a copy of it so that she could play it at parties to make people leave. I read that too. And I guess the reason she got a copy, George Lucas would not give any copies out. In fact, supposedly, this is the only copy he gave out. All the ones you see on YouTube were bootleg copies, right? But Lucas wanted Carrie to do a DVD commentary, and she said, I will only do it if you give me a copy of the Star Wars holiday special. Yeah, I mean, everybody, this was the time when like if you didn't see it live on TV, that was it.
正如我们所说，演员阵容都讨厌它。他们几乎闭口不谈。凯丽·费雪透露，她曾索要过一份拷贝，以便在派对上播放，好让人们赶快离开。我也读到过这个。我想她能拿到拷贝的原因是，乔治·卢卡斯根本不肯发任何拷贝。事实上，据说这是他给出的唯一一份拷贝。你们在YouTube上看到的那些全都是盗版拷贝，对吧？但卢卡斯想让凯丽做DVD评论音轨，而她说：“除非你给我一份《星际大战假日特别节目》的拷贝，否则我绝不做。”是的，我的意思是，各位，那个年代如果不是在电视上直播看，那就没了。
Yeah. I just think it's hilarious that if you went to a party at Carrie Fisher's house and she was ready for you to go she put this on. I know. It makes me laugh. Speaking of George Lucas not wanting to give out any copies of this. I also read that in Star Wars Episode 3 Revenge of the Sith they had to show the Wookiee planet for the first time in the movie.
对。我只是觉得太搞笑了，如果你去凯丽·费雪家参加派对，而她已经准备让你走人了，她就会放这个。我懂。这让我笑死。说到乔治·卢卡斯不想分发这玩意的任何拷贝。我还读到过，在《星际大战前传3：西斯的复仇》（Star Wars Episode 3 Revenge of the Sith）中，他们必须在电影中第一次展示伍基人的星球。
So the artist to portray Kashyyyk had to go to the holiday special. Because it had been established? Because it had been established. It was already in the world, right? So they had to go to George Lucas and ask for a copy. And I guess he was super annoyed about it. That's what I read. George Lucas is famously quoted
所以负责描绘卡什基（Kashyyyk）的艺术家不得不去研究这个假日特辑。因为这个星球已经被设定好了？因为这个星球已经被设定好了。它已经存在于这个世界中了，对吧？所以他们不得不去找乔治·卢卡斯索要一份拷贝。我猜他对此超级恼火。这就是我读到的。乔治·卢卡斯有一句名言流传甚广，
about the Star Wars holiday special. He has said, quote, "'If I had the time and a sledgehammer, I would track down every copy of that show and smash it.'" That's what George Lucas has to say about it. But Ainsley, you found some comments on the YouTube page where we all watch this. What are folks saying there?
关于这个《星际大战假日特别节目》。他说过：“如果我有时间和一把大锤，我会找出这个节目的每一份拷贝并把它砸个粉碎。”这就是乔治·卢卡斯对它的评价。不过，安斯利，你在我们大家看这个节目的那个YouTube页面上发现了一些评论。大家都在说些什么？
Yeah, what's the fan response? Well, it's pretty unanimously bad. One user said, three seconds in and I'm already upset. The Incredible Hulk will not be presented this evening. Oh, yeah, that was the ad before it. Another said, imagine setting your VCR for The Incredible Hulk and coming home to this. One is a spoiler, so I won't say that right now. It's probably OK.
对，粉丝们的反应是怎样的？嗯，几乎是一边倒的差评。有个网友说：“才过去三秒钟我就已经抓狂了。今晚将不播《无敌浩克》（The Incredible Hulk）。”哦，对，那是之前的广告。另一个人说：“想象一下，你把VCR定时录制《无敌浩克》，结果回家看到的是这个。”其中一条涉及剧透，所以我现在不说了。可能也没关系。
Love how all the comments are related to the first 10 minutes of the movie, because no one could clearly make it any further. Yes. This special is the reason Ben gave up during his battle with Vader. He first saw this and thought if I don't die now I'll have to star in it as well. And my favorite because I relate to it is this is what Star Wars looks like to
真喜欢所有评论都跟电影前10分钟有关，因为显然没人能撑得更久了。是的。这个特辑就是欧比旺（Ben）在与达斯·维达（Vader）决斗时放弃抵抗的原因。他第一次看到这个，心想如果我现在不阵亡，以后就得去主演这玩意儿了。我最喜欢的一条，因为我感同身受，那就是：这就是星际大战在
people who don't like Star Wars. Oh amazing. I did see an interview with Mark Hamill where he said at at this point, we should just celebrate it. You know, we should just lean into it, which I think is really, really fun. And now I guess there's even a documentary about this holiday special. It's called A Disturbance in the Force. It came out in 2023, and it kind of shares how this whole thing came about. Well, I told Lee that we were breaking this down this week
不喜欢星际大战的人眼中的样子。太惊艳了。我确实看过马克·哈米尔的一个采访，他说到了这个时候，我们应该好好庆祝它。你知道，我们应该坦然接受它，我觉得这真的非常有意思。现在我猜甚至还有一部关于这个假日特辑的纪录片。它叫《原力大混乱》（A Disturbance in the Force），于2023年上映，它大概讲述了这整个事情是怎么出炉的。嗯，我告诉李我们这周要盘点这个，
and this is what he said. Lee went like this, he went, oh, when I was a little kid, my parents said, do you wanna go to a hockey game or do you wanna stay home and watch the Star Wars holiday special? Oh man, he loves hockey. And he said, I want to stay home and I want to watch the Star Wars holiday special. Oh no. So Lee's dad took his brothers to the hockey game and Lee stayed home
他是这么说的。李当时是这么反应的，他说：“噢，我小时候，我爸妈问我，你是想去冰球比赛，还是想留在家看《星际大战假日特别节目》？”天哪，他太爱冰球了。他说：“我想留在家，我想看《星际大战假日特别节目》。”哦不。所以李的爸爸带着他的兄弟们去了冰球比赛，而李留在了家里
to the hockey game and Lee stayed home and he said about four minutes in he's so greatly regretted his decision and he's remembered it all these years. Oh my gosh the core memory. So everyone we're gonna break it down so sit back relax cuz here it comes. Oh crap, I forgot something. OK. Wait, let me get it. Let me get it. OK. This is part of my bit.
去了冰球比赛，李留在了家里，他说大概过了四分钟他就无比后悔自己的决定，而且这些年来他一直记着这事。哦天哪，核心记忆。所以各位，我们要开始盘点了，所以靠回椅背，放松心情，因为重头戏要来了。哦糟糕，我忘了一件事。好的。等等，我去拿一下。我去拿一下。好的。这是我一个小把戏。
I didn't really forget. Oh. I'm doing a bit. Oh. Did I sell it? Did you really think I forgot something? Of course. OK, before we go to break, I just had one thing
我其实没忘。哦。我在演戏。哦。我演得像吗？你们真的以为我忘东西了吗？当然没有。好的，在我们进入广告之前，我只有一件事
I really needed to say to you. Okay. I just need one thing to help me say it to you. Angela has gotten underneath the podcasting table and I don't know what she's doing. I don't know what's happening. What is that? Oh my gosh. Chewbacca noises Chewbacca noises
真的很想对你说。好的。我只需要一件事来帮我对你说它。安吉拉钻到了播客桌子底下，我不知道她在干嘛。我不知道发生了什么。那是什么？哦天哪。丘巴卡叫声 丘巴卡叫声
Chewbacca noises Chewbacca noises Chewbacca noises Chewbacca noises Chewbacca noises Chewbacca noises Chewbacca noises Chewbacca noises
丘巴卡叫声 丘巴卡叫声 丘巴卡叫声 丘巴卡叫声 丘巴卡叫声 丘巴卡叫声 丘巴卡叫声 丘巴卡叫声
Chewbacca noises Chewbacca noises I love it so much. I'm so tickled by it. I bought it special. And listen, the Chewbacca people speak Shiree Wook, and this is how they say hello. Hello. Angela, I think the rest of the podcast could just be Jenna talking and you speaking Wookie, and that would be the movie. That would be the movie. And I'll just sing from time to time as well and maybe
丘巴卡叫声 丘巴卡叫声 我太喜欢了。我被它逗乐了。我专门买的。听着，丘巴卡他们说的是席瑞语（Shyriiwook），他们是这样说“你好”的。你好。安吉拉，我觉得剩下的播客可以让珍娜一个人说话，而你全程说伍基语，那就能当成那部电影了。那就能当成那部电影了。我偶尔还会唱唱歌，或许
do a cartwheel and then you will have the full experience. I looked up the language Wookie speak because I wanted maybe it sounded better than my interpretation. Oh boy. Oh boy. Well, let's go to break. We'll be back. This segment is brought to you by Macy's. Hey everyone, this is your friendly reminder that the holiday season is upon us. Macy's is our one stop shop for gifting this season. I have found gifts for everyone on my list thanks to the Macy's gift guide.
再翻个跟头，那你就会拥有完整的体验了。我查过伍基语怎么说，因为我希望它听起来比我的演绎更好。天哪。天哪。好吧，我们去个广告。我们马上回来。本环节由梅西百货（Macy's）赞助播出。嘿，大家好，这是给各位的好心提醒，假期即将来临。梅西百货是我们这个季节一站式挑选礼物的好去处。多亏了梅西百货的礼品指南，我在我的清单上为每个人都找到了礼物。
In fact, it was their gift guide titled Home that helped me find the perfect gift for my sister this year. They have such good gift guides. Lady, I'm so excited that we partnered with them this holiday season because they are truly, actually making my holiday shopping so much easier. I know, I know.
事实上，正是他们那份名为“家居”（Home）的礼品指南，帮我找到了今年给我姐姐的完美礼物。他们的礼品指南真的太棒了。女士，我很高兴我们能在今年这个节日季与他们合作，因为他们确实在实际上让我的节日购物变得轻松多了。我懂，我懂。
Because I have spent so much time with the gift guides. So what'd you get your sister? I got her an air fryer. Great. And I know she's gonna be excited about it because she recently told me that her kids new favorite thing to make at home are pan-fried potatoes, but it drives her crazy because of how the oil splatters all over the stove when they
因为我花了很多时间看这些礼品指南。那你给你姐买啥了？我给她买了个空气炸锅。太棒了。我知道她会为此很兴奋，因为她最近告诉我，她家孩子们现在最喜欢在家里做的事情就是煎土豆，但这快把她逼疯了，因为他们做的时候油四处溅到炉灶上，因为我觉得他们喜欢做，但我想他们大概不太喜欢收拾。嗯，通常都是这样，对吧？不管怎样，我觉得我本来是不会想到空气炸锅的，但我看到它出现在礼品指南上了。说到礼品指南，我们也推出了我们自己的梅西百货礼品指南，我们在上面放了我们为节日精选的礼物。所以珍娜，我知道你把空气炸锅加到我们的清单上了。我加了，因为我觉得这东西太有趣了。它有点像成年人的玩具。我觉得这是那种你可能不会自己买，但作为礼物你会非常喜欢的。对，我也有一个。我也很喜欢。传递爱意，送一个空气炸锅。
make it, because I think they like to make it but they don't love to clean it up I guess. Well that's that's usually the case, right? Anyway, I don't think I would have thought of an air fryer but I saw it pop up on the gift guide. Well speaking of gift guides, we also started our own Macy's gift guide where we are putting our picks for the holidays. So Jenna, I know you added the air fryer to our list. I did because I think it's such a fun thing. It's kind of like a toy for adults. I feel like it's something you might not buy yourself, but you would love as a gift. Yeah, I have one too. I love it. Give love, give an air fryer.
你也会在我们的动态里放一个上滑链接对吧？肯定的。总的来说，我非常喜欢小型厨房电器。我喜欢搅拌机、迷你食物料理机、电饭煲。那是我个人的最爱。我要把电饭煲加到我们的礼品指南里。我用电饭煲的频率可高了。嗯，我也在我们的礼品指南里加了一些东西。我儿子一直很想要一双舒服的拖鞋。你知道他以前有那种小孩子的拖鞋，你知道的，就是毛茸茸的那种，现在都穿烂了，但他现在长大了。他是个青少年了，他想要一双舒服暖和的拖鞋，但也得是那种能穿着走到车道上的。没错。所以我给他买了一双很棒的UGG拖鞋。那是UGG男士经典一脚蹬毛绒麂皮拖鞋。
You're going to put a swipe up in our stories too, right? For sure. In general, I love small kitchen appliances. I love a blender, a mini food processor, a rice cooker. That is my personal favorite. I'm gonna add a rice cooker to our gift guide. I use my rice cooker so much. Well, I added a few things to our gift guide as well. So my son has really been wanting a pair of nice slippers. You know he had like his little kids slippers, you know, like the fuzzy ones and they've fallen apart but he's he's older now. He's a teenager and he wanted some cozy slippers but like also ones that you could walk out in the driveway in. Yep. So I got him these great Ugg slippers. They are the Ugg Men's Classic Slip-On Shaggy Suede slippers.
我迫不及待想把它送给他了。而且我在我们的网站上也为自己加了一点小东西。你加了什么？嗯，我的意思是，我喜欢在这个时候穿得有节日气氛。所以我加了一件可爱的红色毛衣，它的正面用白色的字写着“M-A-R-R-Y”（玛丽/节日快乐）。这太符合你的风格了。
I can't wait to give them to him. And I added a little something for me on our site. What did you add? Well, I mean, I love to dress festive this time of year. So I added a cute red sweater, and on the front of it in white, it says Mary, M-E-R-R-Y. That is so you.
它是Cece品牌的，我把它放到了我们的店铺页面上，这样像我这样想要有节日气氛的人就可以去那里买到它。我们真的很希望大家去看看我们的礼品清单。我们在其中倾注了太多的爱与心意，在梅西百货的亲友特卖（Friends and Family）活动中，顶级礼品可额外享受7折优惠，顶级美妆品牌可享5折优惠。这是梅西百货本季度最优惠的活动。顶级礼品可额外享7折优惠，我们最好的美妆品牌可享85折优惠，且满25美元即可享受免费配送。让梅西百货成为你的送礼指南。
It's by Cece, and I put it on our storefront so you know people who are like me and want to be festive can go there and get it. We really hope you'll check out our gift list. We have put so much love and care into it and at Macy's Friends and Family you can take an extra 30% off top gifts and 50% off top beauty brands. It's Macy's best offer of the season. Take an extra 30% off top gifts, plus 15% off our best beauty brands and free shipping starting at $25. Let Macy's be your guide to gifting.
在这个假日季，通过访问我们Instagram个人简介中的链接，直接从我们的梅西百货礼品指南店铺选购我们最喜爱的商品。我们试图在其中填满各种创意，从甜蜜的零食到长筒袜里的惊喜等等。再次提醒，请前往我们的Instagram个人简介获取链接，直接从我们的梅西百货礼品指南店铺进行购物。祝购物愉快！好的，我们回来了，特辑在千年隼号（Millennium Falcon）上开场。丘巴卡和韩·索罗（Han Solo）正风驰电掣地穿梭于太空之中。对。
Shop our favorites this holiday season directly from our Macy's gift guide storefront by visiting the link in our Instagram bio. We tried to fill it with lots of ideas from sweet treats to stocking stuffers and more. Again head to our Instagram bio for the link to shop directly from our Macy's Gift Guide storefront. Happy shopping! All right we are back and the special opens up on the Millennium Falcon. Chewbacca and Han Solo are racing through space. Yeah.
我的意思是，它的开场方式在某种程度上还算挺有希望的。你此时根本不知道前方等待着你的是什么。此时此刻，你还满怀希望。这又是一部星际大战电影。天哪，帝国军队。接下来会发生什么？是的，这就是我们将要揭晓整部电影剧情的时刻，那就是今天是生命日，而丘巴卡正努力赶回家。生命日是一个融合了
I mean, it opens in a somewhat promising way. You have no idea what lies ahead at this point. At this point, you're hopeful. It's another Star Wars movie. Oh my gosh, the Imperial Forces. What's going to happen? Yes, this is when we're going to find out the plot of the whole thing, which is that it is Life Day and Chewbacca is trying to get home. Life Day is a holiday that is a combination of
圣诞节和感恩节的节日。韩·索罗说，我会带你回家，让你赶上和家人一起庆祝。你别担心。对。对。就是这样，各位。这就是剧情。他们能及时赶回家吗？嗯，在那个开场序列之后，我们迎来了一大堆非常健康的片头演职员表。对。
Christmas and Thanksgiving. And Han Solo says, I will get you home in time to celebrate with your family. You don't worry. Yeah. Yeah. That's it, everybody. That's the plot. Will they get home in time? Well, after that opening sequence, we've got a real healthy bunch of opening credits. Yeah.
我们在那里介绍了所有的演员和他们的角色，巴拉巴拉巴拉。现在我们要进入这个故事的核心了。我们以一个木制房屋的外景镜头开场。它是围绕着一棵树建造的。我们只能说这不是一个真正的建筑。这显然是一个画出来的东西。它是假的。
Where we introduce all of the actors and their characters and blah, blah, blah. And now we're going to get into the meat of this story. We open on an exterior shot of a wooden home. It's built around a tree. Let's just say it's not a real structure. This is clearly like a drawing that they're using. It's fakie.
我的意思是，它看起来可能是用火柴棍拼出来的，或者是一幅画。我看不出来。它稍微有点伊沃克人（Ewok）树屋的感觉，但远没有那么酷炫。对，我们现在要推进到内部，那是丘巴卡的家族住所。我当时写下了这个，我看了这部电影四分钟就已经在怀疑自己能不能看完了。好吧，我们见到了这家人。
I mean, it looks like it was made out of matchsticks maybe or it's a drawing. I couldn't tell. It had a little it has a little bit of like a Ewok treehouse vibe but nowhere near like as cool looking. Yeah we're gonna now push inside and it is Chewbacca's family home. And I wrote this, I'm four minutes into this movie and I'm already wondering if I can finish it. Well, we meet the family.
我们见到了丘巴卡的妻子马拉（Mala）、他的儿子兰皮（Lumpy），以及他的父亲伊奇（Itchy）。这里的开场镜头看起来，你知道的，伊奇可能在削木头。他在削一个木制的星际战机，可能是T-65 X翼战机，也许吧。兰皮一直拿着他的木制X翼战机在爷爷的脑袋旁飞来飞去，伊奇气坏了。他冲他咆哮。他就像是，啊，伊奇有着严重的地包天。
We meet Chewbacca's wife, Mala, his son, Lumpy, and his father, Itchy. And the opening shot here, it looks like, you know, Itchy is maybe whittling. He's whittling a wooden starfighter, maybe the T-65 X-wing, maybe. And Lumpy keeps flying his wooden X-wing by his grandfather's head and Itchy's getting really ticked off. He like growls at him. He's like, ah, Itchy has a severe underbite.
而且没有牙齿。没有牙齿。我觉得这让人看了很不舒服。这有点难以直视。他在四分零七秒时让人看了有点心里发毛。镜头切到了厨房里的马拉。她系着围裙。看起来她正准备倒垃圾。嗯，这里插播一个小插语，我真的很喜欢她厨房里的光线。她在树屋里采光极好。她还有一些植物。但这就是你对那个场景的全部感受。
And no teeth. No teeth. I found it upsetting. It's a little hard to look at. He's a little unsettling to look at at four minutes and seven seconds. It cuts over to Mala in the kitchen. She's wearing an apron. Looks like she's starting to take out the trash. Um, little side note here. I really loved the light in her kitchen. She gets great light in her tree house. She had some plants. But that was your takeaway from the scene.
她确实有。祝她过得好。祝她过得好。真为你高兴，马拉。你还有些植物。看起来她有一个带抽油烟机的好炉灶，可能还有一个厨房中岛。客厅里有一个大肚壁炉。我的意思是，这真是一个相当不错的树屋。
She does. Good for her. Good for her. Good for you, Mala. You've got some plants. It looked like she has a nice stove top with a hood, maybe a kitchen island. The living room has a potbelly fireplace. I mean, this is a pretty nice tree house.
他们铺的是草皮地毯，我觉得这是一个奇怪的选择。嗯，他们住在树屋里。但为什么要吧户外搬到室内呢？我不知道。伙计们，兰皮现在非常想要吃点零食。那里有一碗什么东西，可能是虫子。很难看出来。
They have turf for carpeting, which I thought was a strange choice. Well, they're in a tree house. But why bring the outside in? I don't know. Lumpy now, guys, really wants a snack. There's a bowl of something, maybe worms. It's hard to tell.
而他妈妈就像是，不行不行，你把该死的垃圾倒了。等等。我需要我们注意的一点是，除了伍基语，没有人说任何其他语言。哦对，全都是那种，不过这只是我的理解。兰皮把垃圾拿到他们的门廊上。然后他看着栏杆外面。伙计们，他们在一棵树上非常、非常高的地方。你能听到鸟叫声。兰皮正探着头往下看，你猜他决定做什么？在栏杆顶上走平衡木？对。
And his mom is like, uh-uh, you take out the dang trash. But hold on. I just need us to note that no one is speaking anything but Wookie language. Oh yeah, it's all just like, but this is my interpretation. Lumpy takes the trash out to their porch. Then he looks over the banister. You guys, they are high, high up in a tree. You can hear birds. Lumpy is like peering over and guess what he decides to do? Walk on the top of the railing? Yeah.
搞什么鬼？这太高了。非常危险。我在那个时候压力非常大。是的。与此同时，回到屋里，对兰皮在走走平衡木一无所知的是，伊奇还在削木头，而马拉走向了她的书架。
What the heck? It's super high. It's very dangerous. I was very stressed out during this time. Yeah. Meanwhile, back inside, Oblivious, that Lumpy is like doing a tightrope walk, Itchy is still whittling, and Molly goes over to her bookshelf.
她拿起了相框里丘巴卡的照片。她看起来真的很担心，我确实注意到书架上有几样东西。他们有很好的音响。光线很好，音响不错。是的。好的。现在我想跟你们多聊聊布鲁斯·瓦兰奇（Bruce Valanch）说过的话。他曾被引述说过这样的话：
She gets a photo of Chewbacca in a frame. She's really looking worried, and I did notice a few things on the bookshelf. They have very nice speakers. Great light, good speakers. Yes. Okay. I want to tell you a little bit about what Bruce Valanche had to say now. He was quoted as saying, quote,
“你选择围绕不会说话的角色来构建一个故事。”他接着说，这是乔治·卢卡斯的愿景，谁也无法让他改变。他说：“当然，星际大战太宏大了，他已经获得了无数次的验证。”所以他具备了一个导演需要具备的素质，那就是对个人愿景的这种疯狂信念，而他某种程度上就是要让它行之有效。他还分享说，是乔治·卢卡斯给丘巴卡的父亲和儿子起名叫伊奇和兰皮的。但我想这些名字其实是
You've chosen to build a story around characters who don't speak. He went on to say this was George Lucas's vision and he could not be moved. He said, and of course, Star Wars was so gigantic that he had been validated 100 times over. So he had what a director needs to have, which is this insane belief in their personal vision, and he was somehow gonna make it work. He also shared that it was George Lucas who named Chewbacca's father and son Itchy and Lumpy. But I guess the names are actually abbreviations
Atichococ和Lumpawarump的简称。这听起来就像你不得不临时编个名字一样，女士。这就像Belly。你当时叫什么名字？哦，Betsy Bellywally？对。对。你也能想出星际大战的名字。
of Atichococ and Lumpawarump. This sounds like when you have to make up a name, lady. This is like Belly. What was your name? Oh, Betsy Bellywally? Yes. Yeah. You could come up with Star Wars names.
对。它们也让我想起迈克尔（Michael）给他的孩子们起的名字。有点像。或者当你让你的孩子们给家里的宠物起名字时，你就会得到兰皮和伊奇。好吧，那是他们的昵称。好的，兰皮从（你知道的）走平衡木的活动中回来了，他非常兴奋地跑进来。他拿着这个灰色的方形小东西。你猜是什么？就像是一个磁带。他们有一个巨大的录音机。但它可不是普通的录音机。它能播放音乐，而且还会弹出一个小小的心形全息影像，
Yeah. They also remind me of the names that Michael named his children. A little bit. Or when you ask your kids to name the family pet, you get Lumpy and Itchy. Well, those are their nicknames. Okay, well Lumpy is back from, you know, walking on the balance beam thing and he runs in very excited. He's got this little gray square. Guess what? It's like a cassette tape. They have an enormous tape player. But it's not just any kind of tape player. It plays music and like a little tiny hologram pops up
不同的外星人排着队出来，穿着色彩斑斓的服装跳舞。他们玩杂耍。他们表演杂技。想象一下一个微型的太阳马戏团（Cirque du Soleil）。那就是太阳马戏团。太阳马戏团刚刚崭露头角。这就是太阳马戏团。这就是太阳马戏团。太阳马戏团刚刚崭露头角，而这就是太阳马戏团，女士。
and different aliens parade out and they dance in these colorful outfits. They juggle. They do acrobatics. Imagine a tiny Cirque du Soleil. It was Cirque du Soleil. Cirque du Soleil had just hit the scene. And this was Cirque du Soleil. It was Cirque du Soleil. Cirque du Soleil had just hit the scene and this was Cirque du Soleil, lady.
太疯狂了。是的。好吧，有一个家伙穿着一件非常大、绿色的多叶紧身衣。他有点负责管事。想象一下瓶中精灵的氛围，但后来他变得更大了。对，是的。
That is crazy. Yes. Well, there's one dude in a really big, green, leafy leotard. He's kind of in charge of things. Imagine like a genie in a bottle vibe, but then he becomes bigger. Yes, yeah.
除了伍基语，仍然没有任何对话。不，完全没有。我们现在已经深入大约10分钟了。对，你知道的，兰皮想继续看他的全息影像磁带，但他妈妈真的很想让他做家务，她一直指着厨房里的某个东西，然后他只好去洗碗。现在马拉要尝试
There still has been no talking outside of the Wookie language. No, there hasn't been. We're a good like 10 minutes deep now. Yeah, and you know, Lumpy wants to keep watching his hologram tape, but his mom really wants him to do chores and she keeps pointing to something in the kitchen and then he has to go dry the dishes. Well now Mala is gonna attempt to
扫描任何进港的飞船，你知道的，丘巴卡在回家的路上了吗？一开始她没有成功，但她最终联系上了卢克·天行者和R2D2。对，事情是这样的，他们的房子里有太多的电脑屏幕了。我觉得他们的电脑屏幕太多了，科技感太浓了，科技感太浓了，因为她走到那台大型家用电脑前，结果它不管用了。然后她在书架上有一个秘密隔间，她把门推开，里面还有另一台较小的电脑，他们就跟卢克·天行者视频通话。他接通了。他跟R2D2在一起，我觉得我们需要听听他们的电话。好的。
scan for any incoming ships you know can is Chewbacca on his way and initially she has no success but she eventually contacts Luke Skywalker and R2D2. Yeah here's the thing they have so many computer screens in their house I think they have too much computer screen too much technology, too much technology, because she goes to the big family computer and it doesn't work. Then she has a secret compartment in the bookshelf that she slides the doors open and there's another smaller computer and they video call Luke Skywalker. He answers. He's with R2D2 and I think we need to hear their phone call. All right.
你好，马拉。碧池。你觉得这个怎么样？丘巴卡在哪？现在不行，R2。等一下，我感觉这有点不对劲。让我把它修好。这就是他们的电话。就是这样。如果你想知道这部电影的前10分钟是什么样的，那就是这样。好吧，卢克向她保证，尽管缺乏通讯，但韩和丘巴卡正在回家的路上，因为拜托，他以前从来没有错过过生命日，这次也不会错过。他让她笑一笑。
Hello, Mala. Bitchy. How you like that? Where's Chewbacca? Not now R2. Oh wait a minute, I don't like the looks of this. Let me get this fixed. That's their phone call. That's it. If you want to know what the first 10 minutes of this movie are like, that's it. Well, Luke is going to assure her that Han and Chewbacca are on their way despite the lack of communication because come on, he's never missed a life day before and he's not going to miss it this time. He tells her to smile.
我刚刚说什么来着？我知道，我知道。还有一个要出场。哦，确实有。我要指出来。我指出来了。就是那个吻。哦，对，我懂。
What did I box about? I know, I know. I there's another one coming up. Oh, there is. I'm going to point out. I pointed it out. It's that kiss. Oh, yeah, I know.
好的。对，他让她笑一笑。现在，马拉要联系肖恩·丹（Sean Dan）。对，但她又在电脑前弄了好久。她得输入一堆东西。最后，屏幕上闪烁出字样。上面写着：贸易站伍基星球C。嗯，而肖恩·丹是由阿特·卡尼（Art Carney）扮演的。
Okay. Yeah, he tells her to smile. Well now, Mala is going gonna reach out to Sean Dan. Yeah, but again, she's on the computer for a long time. She has to type a bunch of stuff. Finally, it flashes up on the screen. It says Trading Post Wookie Planet C. Mm-hmm, and Sean Dan is played by Art Carney.
阿特·卡尼是一位演员兼喜剧演员。他是《蜜月期》（The Honeymooners）的主演之一。他饰演了埃德·诺顿（Ed Norton），与杰基·格里森（Jackie Gleason）演对手戏。他曾获得七次艾美奖提名，并赢得了六次。他还获得了1974年的奥斯卡奖和金球奖。所以就在这之前，他在1974年凭借这部电影《哈里和托ント》（Harry and Tonto）赢得了奥斯卡奖和金球奖。讲的是一个老年人跟他的宠物猫
Art Carney was an actor and a comedian. He was one of the stars of The Honeymooners. He played Ed Norton, opposite Jackie Gleason. He was nominated for seven Emmy Awards, and he won six. He also won an Academy Award and a Golden Globe in 1974. So right before this, he won an Academy Award and a Golden Globe in 1974. So right before this, he won an Academy Award and a Golden Globe for this movie, Harry and Tonto. It's about an elderly man who goes on a road trip
一起踏上公路旅行的故事。我想让你听听他击败了哪些人。好的。阿尔伯特·芬尼（Albert Finney）、达斯汀·霍夫曼（Dustin Hoffman）、杰克·尼科尔森（Jack Nicholson）和阿尔·帕西诺（Al Pacino）。哇。我只想让大家明白，我们请来扮演肖恩·丹这个角色的这位演员是多么的重量级。嗯。
with his pet cat. I want you to hear the people he beat. Okay. Albert Finney, Dustin Hoffman, Jack Nicholson, and Al Pacino. Wow. I just want everyone to understand the gravity of the actor that we got to play this role of Sean Dan. Mm-hmm. And
他的第一句台词——准备好欣赏这里的美妙文笔了吧——他说：“哦，帝国军官，我想你大概想看我的身份证件吧。”嗯。然后用一种非常低沉的声音，这个头盔看起来有点像一顶软帽、还留着一大撮胡子的帝国军官说：“不，我下班了。我是来参观你的商店的。”他有着非常低沉的声音。这把我逗乐了。对。
his first line of dialogue, get ready for the beautiful writing here, he says, oh Imperial officer, I guess you'll want to see my identification. Mm-hmm. And then in a very deep voice, this Imperial officer whose helmet kind of looks like a bonnet and he has a really big mustache, he says, no, I'm off duty. I've come to look at your shop. He's got this really deep voice. It cracked me up. Yeah.
而正当这个军官在那里时，马拉打电话给他，所以他们现在得打起哑谜说暗话了。对。因为，你知道，为什么？他们为什么要说暗话？这一点我实在搞不懂。他们为什么在这？他们为什么在这个伍基星球上？
And Mala is going to call him while this officer is there, so they're gonna have to kind of talk in code now. Yeah. Because, you know, why? Why are they talking in code? This I did not understand. Why are they here? Why are they on this Wookie planet?
他们为什么不想让丘巴卡回家过生命日？我们为什么要偷偷摸摸的？我不明白。嗯，丘巴卡是抵抗力量的一部分。所以也许有这个原因。但在星际大战结尾时，难道我们不是已经摆脱了所有这些帝国势力吗？难道那没有发生吗？
Why don't they want Chewbacca to come home for Life Day? Why are we sneaking? I don't get it. Well, Chewbacca is part of the resistance. So maybe there's that. But at the end of Star Wars, didn't we get rid of all this Imperial business? Didn't that happen?
为什么他们不想让丘巴卡回家过生命日？我们为什么要偷偷摸摸的？我不明白。好吧，丘巴卡是抵抗力量的一部分。所以也许是因为这个。但在《星球大战》的最后，我们不是已经铲除了所有这些帝国势力吗？难道那没有发生吗？
They blew up a whole planet, right? Am I remembering this correctly? No, you're remembering it correctly. No, you're right. It doesn't make sense. After Star Wars and the happy ending of blowing up this planet, now in this Christmas special, I'm learning that we're under the thumb of the Imperial
forces again. But they blew up the Death Star. But they didn't obliterate the entire room. They didn't get rid of the Imperial army. But they got rid of almost everyone in it. They got rid of their floating Death Ray machine. Reorganize so quickly and have everyone under control again. What was even the point of blowing up the Death Star four seconds later?
Everyone's scared of the officers again? Who's in charge, by the way? Who's in charge? Why do we need to see this Imperial officer in a gadget shop? He doesn't really like anything. My favorite moment, I think we need to hear it, when we learn that you can buy a pocket aquarium. Listen to his reaction to this gadget.
Ah, here we are. Here it is. A pocket-sized aquarium. Wonderful, isn't it? And you could take it with you anyway. And the tank is a snap to clean. I hate fish. I'm telling you, I live for this guy.
His voice, his reaction to everything. This scene is bonkers. Well, at the end of the scene, Sean Dan is going to convince the officer that he needs this special groomer, and he's going to discuss the multiple uses of the groomer with the officer. He's going to make a sale, and I'd like us to hear it. Just a groomer, you say? What's the luck more than that.
I bet every of you haven't read the instructions of the warranty and the guarantee. Besides shaving and hair trimming, it's guaranteed to lift stains off clothing, faces and hands. Cleans teeth, fingers and toenails, washes eyes, pierces ears, calculates, modulates and syncopates life rhythms, and can repeat the entire imperial penal code or 17 volumes in half the time of the old xp21. Just the thing to keep you squeaky clean. Mm-hmm. And you guys if you see it it's like a stick with a brush on the end. Capulet, modulate. Well after this we are going to cut to Darth Vader. Well, after this, we are going to cut to Darth Vader. Yeah. How exciting.
Very exciting. Darth Vader tells his henchmen that he wants to find and identify the rebels, even if it means searching every home in the system. I have a fun fact for you. What? James Earl Jones is the voice of Darth Vader, but he was originally uncredited in the Star Wars movies So this special marks the first time he was actually credited as the voice of Darth Vader. Oh, I have a tidbit for you What is it? Apparently George Lucas is not in the credits. He's not
That's what I read Hmm. I didn't notice. Mm-hmm We're gonna go back to the Wookiee home because that's where most of this special is set. Mala's busy cooking. She's watching a cooking show. Yeah. She is watching Gormanda, who is played by Harvey Corman,
sort of a take on Julia Child, I think. This is one of his three characters he plays. Yes, Harvey Corman rose to fame thanks to his role on the Carol Burnett show. During his 10-year run on the show, he received six Emmy nominations and he won four. He also starred in the Mel Brooks film's Blazing Saddles and High Anxiety, and the Disney film Herbie Goes Bananas. And I was relieved when this bit came up. I did appreciate this comedy bit. Well, that's what he's there for. Yes.
He is wearing a gray sort of pompadour wig with a pink dress and a cape. His hands have these big gloves that come up. There might be more hands coming. There will be. Chef Gourmanda is teaching you how to make Bantha Surprise. This is a traditional dish served on life day and Mala is following the instructions. It seems like the way you make it is you just kind of whip things into a frenzy. Yes, here's an audio clip. Step one, we stir the mixture.
Stir, stir, stir, stir, stir, stir, stir. Stir, stir, stir, stir. Very nice. Now step two, while we're stirring, we also whip. So it's stir, whip, stir, whip, whip, whip, stir's stir, whip, stir, whip, whip, whip, stir. Stir, whip, stir, whip, whip, whip, stir. Let's try it again together at an increased tempo because precision is very important in this recipe
and we do want to have a fine consistency, don't we? So, and on the count of one, stir, whip, stir, whip, whip, whip, stir. Stir, whip, stir, whip, whip, whip, stir. Come on faster altogether now, cooking can be fun. Stir, whip, stir, whip, whip, whip, stir. Stir, whip, stir, whip, whip, whip, stir. Wah!
There you go. Yeah. And during all the stirring and whipping, Gourmandia gets a third arm and then a fourth arm. Yeah, well, here's what happens. After that segment, Gourmandia's like, you also gotta beat it. So then another arm comes then a fourth arm. Yeah, well, here's what happens. After that segment, Garmanda's like, you also gotta beat it. So then another arm comes out to beat it.
And then you've gotta taste it. And another comes out to taste it. And then there's four arms going, this is comedy gold, you guys. I mean, Harvey is trying to keep up that one of the arms is feeding him, the other one's whipping, the other one's stirring, one's beating, his wig starts to fall apart.
I mean, hilarious. Angela, did you know what Banthas were? They serve as mounts for Tuscan raiders, and the two share a close, almost mystical bond. But Wookiees eat them. Oh. Yeah, they have big horns, they're like giant sheep. Oh, that's right, that's what they are, andes eat them. Oh, they have big big horns. They're like giant sheep. Oh, that's right
That's what they are and they ride them. They look like a giant sheep. Woolly mammoth. I know what they are now I just didn't know the name. Well, you know what what is this kind of like eating a horse? I mean, I it feels like it's eating a unicorn because the thing has a mystical bond with its rider or Eating a dragon or something. I mean I don't know but the Wookiees love it. I'll have you all know that if you would like you can purchase the Star Wars Life Day cookbook. I'm holding it in my hands right now. It contains, quote, official holiday recipes from a galaxy far, far away. And this was released after the holiday special.
And there is a recipe for Bantha Surprise. Which I thought maybe Josh could make for us. Yes. And he did. Jenna emailed Josh. Josh was like, Angela, I just got a really weird email from Jenna. I was like, what do you mean?
She was like, she wants me to make a type of stew for the podcast? Yeah, if you look at the recipe, it is basically a recipe for beef stew. Yes, it's got carrots and onions, celery. And so I'm excited to try it. I brought it today. Well the human version, the recipe calls for beef rather than bantha. And Cassie, I know you're a vegetarian and you won't be able to partake. So I did make us a special punch according to the Life Day Cookbook that you can have. What's it called?
It's called Joe Blasto Punch. Oh. Do you know who Joe Blasto is? I guess Joe Blasto is a classic Husties Life Day jingle. It's a song. Joe Blasto is a song, not a person. I guess it's a song. It's not in the special.
The song is not in the special. You sing it on life day? Yeah, and then here are the words in the cookbook. Oh, sing it. Okay. Make up your own tunes. It's written in both Wookie and English. Do you want me to do the Wookie part with my mask
and you do the English part? Sure. Okay. I don't know the melody. Rumor has it that R3X, the DJ droid over at Oga's Cantina has a collection of Joe Blasto remixes so extensive that it could play all life day without ever repeating. So here's the Wookiee. I love that you're standing
over my shoulder as if this means anything to you. And I'll sing this part in a melody that I make up on the spot. And then I'll sing the Wookie part. Yeah sure over my shoulder. Okay. Are you ready? Mm-hmm. Blasto Joe Blasto Blasto Mooli Ra O Ta Pan Wai Yataka Bo Eopi Chopa G Balakaya Tup I can't I can't that's all I can do that's all I can do no one wants to hear us do that. I apologize. I don going to get out the Bantha Surprise. I'm going to get out the Joe Blasto punch and we'll be right back. Okay everyone, we're back. We've got our Bantha Surprise, our stew, and we have our punch. Ainsley is also a vegetarian, so Sam, Angela, let's try our Bantha Surprise. Here we go. I mean, it's stew.
It's a beef stew. This is great. Mm-hmm. I highly recommend. If you base the movie off of this, this movie's great. The movie is terrific. Yeah. Well, we'll put the recipe in our stories.
Josh will show you how to make it. All right. Now, let me try my punch. By the way, the punch, I should tell you what's in it. Right? This punch is insane, by the way. Insane in a good way? I need a sip of water.
I don't think I can go from beef stew to this. It looks like a rainbow ice cream in a cup. Well, here's what it is. It is cranberry juice, pineapple juice, 7-Up, and then you mix that together and you top it with a scoop of rainbow sherbet. Here we go. Okay everybody and Ainsley, Cassie, you've got some. I told you, this isn't a game Okay, here we go. It was more tart than I expected. The combination of- Oh my Lord.
Of like rich beef stew. I can't believe you didn't take a sip of water between the two. Chased with this punch. Okay, let me take another sip. All areas of the tongue. It makes my mouth want to expel it. I want to...
I don't know if it's because I've had the mayonnaise and olives, but I'm like, this ain't so bad. Yeah, this is fine. Nothing can ever be as bad as that. Ainsley, Cassie, how did you like the punch? It tastes exactly the way it looks and kind of like what I imagine unicorn droppings to taste like. Yeah, it's way too tart, but it's close, but not as good as this punch my grandma makes
for the holidays, which is just high C, ginger ale, and sherbert. Ooh! And that's really sweet and yummy and highly recommend. But so much sugar. Well Ainsley, you saw me make it. I measured it per the instructions. You did.
It looks like something like when our kids were young and we played potion, you know, like make your own potion. And it was like, what do we got in the kitchen that I'll let them pour into a cup? Oh, you know what it looks like when you get one of those lush bath bombs? Yes. And it gets all frothy and rainbowy.
And like stains your bathtub. Exactly. Yeah. Well, I guess Wookie's really like a tart drink at the holidays. But okay, so I recommend the Bantha Surprise. I would pass on the Joe Blasto punch. I'm not hating the punch. Okay.
All right, everybody. Well, let's keep going with our breakdown, but I want to say I haven't hated this experience. I feel like maybe my tone so far is communicating a type of grumpiness. That's the highest compliment Jenna Fisher can give. I didn't hate it. I, you know, it's this experience,
I look back on it with fondness in a way. Anyway, all right. We're gonna get back on the Millennium Falcon again and Han Solo is still having a hard time getting Chewie to his home planet. Well, lady, the coordinates weren't the best and they came out of hyperspace into an Imperial convoy. I've got some gems from Han Solo.
How about this line? This is one life day we won't soon forget. And this one, why do I always think taking you home for life day is going to be easy? Why does he always think that? I don't know. But guess what? I just lost control of the remote cannons. I got to go to the back and operate them manually. How do you operate them manually? I don't know. We're never going to see. We don't spend too much time. Well now the Empire is is gonna declare martial law.
No ships are gonna be permitted in or out without further notice. I have one thing to say. One thing? Go ahead. The number of times the Empire has to pop on your TV screen, it's constant. They're popping up all the time to tell you something.
I'm like, can you turn it off? I know. Do you have to have these people just popping up at your bar, at your home? Also, I guess they can see you. They can just pop up and they see you. Like, what if you're walking through your house, like, post shower and they just pop up on your screen? I didn't think they could see you. I thought you could only see them. but you could only see them. Well, it's not clear. It's not clear.
Well, now Sean Dan is gonna come over to the Wookiee home. Yeah, he's got a toy for Lumpy, and I thought it was a sewing machine for Mala, but it's not. It's a projector. I don't know what he gives Mala, but before he gives her the gift, she gotta give him a little kiss on the cheek.
Give him a kiss on the cheek for a gift she didn't ask for. Why, why, why doesn't Sean Dan's shirt have a button or a zipper? It is like all the way to his navel. It is open. It's very open. A lot of open real estate there.
Yeah. He is going to give Itchy a proton pack so that he can get his mind evaporator working. Yeah, it's like he sits down on like an old timey hair salon dryer and you know he kind of leans down to Itchy and kind of smirks and goes, I mean, this is wow. And then if you know what I mean, happy life day. And I do mean happy life day. I'm like, what's with the creepy dialogue? And then- What's with the creepy dialogue?
It's foreshadowing for what we're about to see. Here's what happens. Itchy puts this virtual reality headset on. He sits under it. It's like a hairdryer. Yeah. And then Mermia is this very sexy holographic image played by Diane Carroll. I just want you guys to hear. I want you to hear some of the things she's saying. Yeah, let's just listen to it. Yeah. Because she's wearing a sparkly wig and this off the shoulder gown.
So just imagine Diane Carroll looking incredible. Very, very sexy. And Bob Mackie. This is the gift that Sean gives to the grandpa. Yeah. Oh, yes. I can feel my creation. I'm getting your message.
Are you getting mine? We are excited, aren't we? We'll just relax. Just relax. We can have a good time, can't we? Oh. Hmm. I'll tell you a secret. I find you adorable. I'll tell you a secret.
I find you adorable. I find you adorable. I find you adorable. Yeah, he keeps rewinding it. She says it over and over. This is crazy to me. Grandpa is sitting in the middle of the kitchen, getting off. He's... Happy holidays.
She's going to go on to say things like, I am your fantasy. I am your experience. I am your pleasure. I am your experience. I am your pleasure. Experience me. Then she's gonna perform a song. This was an original song written for the special
called This Minute Now. And it is the least melodic song I've ever heard in my life. And I thought we should listen to some of it. Really? Cause there's one more coming up that's gonna give it a run for its money. ["If We Could Only Bend This Minute"] If we could only bend this minute,
infinitely extend this minute, then I could live my whole life right now Reality is sweet this minute Okay, I can't anymore with it. Okay, that was enough. It sounds like when you sing to your cat. Or when you sing to your pets. Yeah, it does. It really does. Can I talk to you though about Diane Carroll? Yes, please. Diane Carroll is such a freaking badass.
Diane Carroll is such a freaking badass. She was an actress, a singer, a model, and an activist. She starred in this television show called Julia, and this role was significant because it was the first American television show to star a black woman in a non-stereotypical role. And she won the Golden Globe for her performance. She also received an Emmy nomination. She didn't win, but she was the first black woman nominated for a Primetime Emmy award.
She was also the first black woman to win the Tony Award for best actress in a musical, for her role in the musical No Strings. She's very famous for playing Dominique Devereux in the Primetime Soap Opera dynasty. And she has appeared on Grey's Anatomy. She's a badass. She is an absolute powerhouse.
And, you know, I'm sort of noting all of the cameo stars. The level of their fame. These were like huge gets for this Star Wars special. And we haven't even gotten to be Arthur yet. No. Well now Princess Leia and C-3PO are gonna contact the Wookiees. And lady, this conversation,
it's like, I know we keep saying this where you're just kinda like, what? I have to read it to you. I transcribed it. Oh. They come on the screen and Princess Leia says, to Mala, happy life day. And then Mala says a bunch of stuff, right?
And then C-3PO translates and says, she says it might seem like a happy life day for you, but personally she's seen happier ones. Princess Leia doesn't react at all. She goes, I don't want to tie up the channels. Can you put Wookie or Han on the phone? Like what? She's just told you she's upset. She's like, yeah, can you put someone else on the phone? Then Mala says a bunch more stuff and basically they find out that they haven't arrived yet. There's been no communication. It's the same information that we started the special with. Yes. We have to repeat it over and over again. Everyone who Mala calls or anyone who calls Mala. But guess what Princess Leia's reaction is to this. What? She says, are you alone? And Mala says, no, I have a friend here.
And Leia goes, can I talk to him? Like what, what the fuck? Why, why can't Mala speak for herself? So now Sean Dan comes to the screen and Leia asks him to take care of the Wookiees until Chewie's arrival and that she'll be contacting him again soon. She couldn't tell Mala that.
She couldn't say hang tight. Exactly. Mala can understand her. She could have just said that right to Mala. It's not like Sean Dan then translates it into Wookie. Exactly. It's just hilarious to me that Princess Leia just keeps saying, is there someone else I can talk to? All right, we're back on the Millennium Falcon. We're going to check in. Han Solo decides they need to land on the north side of the planet for safety reasons. There's just too much imperial traffic. It's going to be a long walk. Chewbacca's not happy about it.
Now there is a commotion in the Wookie home. Mala and Lumpy assume that it is Chewbacca who has arrived at last. So she opens her front door only to discover two storm troopers and an Imperial officer. Yeah, they sort of scan the place and then they say, all right, this unit is occupied by four Wookiees,
two males and one adult female and one male child. Where is the other male? Yeah, where is he? The first thing they're gonna do is check out Sean Dan's identification and it checks out. But Lumpy is upset, he kinda growls at the guard and Sean is trying to get Mala to come in the kitchen cause he has a plan.
He's gonna try to distract the storm troopers and he plays that music video box, which I think is the gift that he gave her, for one of the stormtroopers and he plays that music video box, which I think is the gift that he gave her for one of the Stormtroopers and he watches Jefferson Starship. I was very confused because what are they distracting them from? They're keeping them in the home
by engaging them in this music box, but really everybody, this is an excuse to get a performance from Jefferson Starship. Taking you back in time, Jefferson Starship was huge. They were originally Jefferson Airplane, and you might know their hit, Somebody to Love. Let's take a listen. to realize all the joy within you dies Don't you want somebody to love Don't you need somebody to love
Wouldn't you love somebody to love You better find somebody to love. You better find somebody to love. That's right. We love that. Yeah. Right? They were a very popular band. They're from San Francisco.
In fact, they were one of the pioneering bands of psychedelic rock. Two songs from their breakout album, Surrealistic Pillow, were on Rolling Stone's list of 500 greatest songs of all time. One was Somebody to Love and the other was White Rabbit. Remember that song? But shortly before this special came out, they had broken up. And a few of the original band members created a new band called Jefferson Starship.
And they... Not an airplane. Nope. Still a flying object. Correct. Still Jefferson. Not Jefferson Submarine. No, no, no. Flying in the air. Flying in the air. Could have been Jefferson Jet. Maybe. Yeah. Jefferson Boeing. Jefferson hot air balloon. Jefferson kite. All things that are in the sky. They went with Jefferson starship. Big Bersh stop. Jefferson eagle.
This is making us loopy. Breaking us down is making us loopy. Okay, well in this special, they played a song that they wrote called light the sky on fire. During production though, the song was given a different title. This was the working title of the song.
So this is what would have been like on a script, like now Jefferson Starship plays this song. They changed it to Light the Sky on Fire when they released it, but the working title was, and I can't believe this didn't stick because it's so rolls off the tongue. It is. It is. It has parentheses in it. It is. Cigar-shaped object, parentheses vanished without a trace. What? Can you believe that that name didn't stick?
Cigar-shaped object? Cigar-shaped object vanished without a trace, was the original title of the song. This appearance marked Marty Balin's final appearance with Jefferson Starship. He was one of the members who broke off. Mm-hmm. The lyrics of the song mention a quote... Cigar. Great God? I didn't get the cigar. Oh, here this might be it. They mention a great
god named Copacan who quote, came from the stars and vanished. So is Copacan a cigar shaped? Who is Copacan? Do we hear about this person later in Star Wars? Not that comes to memory. We don't know. Okay. Well, the version that they played on the special was never released, but a shortened single was released. But rather than listen to it, Angela, I would like to instead take you back to the late 80s to your middle school mixer, okay? So that we can listen to this song by Jefferson Starship.
Starship. You're welcome. The pony, remember the pony? We're doing the pony. That's right. Get my high tops with my scrunchie socks. Crimp my hair. We needed this palette cleanse. We did. We really did. We built this city. We did. That was the song that we couldn't wait to come on at the mixers when I was in seventh and eighth
grade. Yeah. All right. Well, we're basically going to go now from a five-minute musical performance to a ten-minute cartoon. Well, here's what happened. You know, Lumpy, he kind of growls at a guard, and the Stormtrooper's like, really mean. They shove Itchy to the ground. Lumpy starts freaking out. The General says, keep him quiet or else. Yeah.
Or else what? So Mala puts on one of Lumpy's favorite cartoons. The stormtrooper walks over. He's like, what's this all about? And then quickly Lumpy pretends to be playing like a video game and then when he walks away it cuts to he's watching this cartoon. Why he couldn't know that he's watching a cartoon I don't know. It's about the resistance. That's probably why. Oh, so maybe it's like, right. But while he's watching the cartoon, the stormtroopers are going to supposedly search the residence. How big is the residence?
I can see the whole bottom floor, and when they go upstairs, it looks like one bedroom. It's just lumpy's room up there. It's not that large. When the cartoon came on, it's called The Faithful Wookie, and I didn't watch it. I watched the whole thing. I just, I just, I couldn't watch it. I watched it.
It's much better than the holiday special, truly. If you're going to watch anything, just watch this. Well, according to the Nielsen data, you can see that the ratings for the special fall off after the cartoon. People stayed for the cartoon and then they were like, I'm out. You can find just the cartoon on YouTube now and you don't have to watch the special. But basically, I'll sum it up for you.
Luke Skywalker, C-3PO and R2-D2, they're searching for a talisman and the Millennium Falcon crashes on the water moon of Panna with the main characters on board. Then they run into Boba Fett who saves Luke from a giant monster and he claims to be there to help them but as it turns out he's actually working for Darth Vader. Well here's the fun fact this cartoon introduced the character of Boba Fett to the Star Wars universe. Well some might think that but yes it introduced everyone to Boba Fett in a television medium, on a screen, but some fans might be surprised to know that the very first proper public appearance of Boba Fett wasn't on the big screen or even on TV, Boba first appeared at a parade
for the San Isilmo County Fair in September of 1978. He was in a parade. Before he was ever on screen, he was in a parade. How did anyone know who he was? How do you end up in the parade? Well, I will tell you, there is a documentary called Under the Helmet, The Legacy of Boba Fett on Disney Plus,
and it talks all about it. Huh. Well, there you go. I have a question about the cartoon, because I did watch a little bit of it, and I am trying to wrap my head around it. So what's happening is Lumpy is watching a cartoon about his actual dad.
Yeah, his dad must be famous. Cause his dad is Han Solo. He's been made into a cartoon. Okay, he loved it. Now we're gonna cut back and see that the Wookie home is just being completely destroyed by the troopers and this officer. They found nothing, they've trashed Lumpy's
room and then the officer is like, clean up your room. I think it's hilarious to trash a child's room. So funny. They discover that Lumpy stuffed animal, which was a bantha, had been decapitated. Well, they ripped his head off. I know. They're jerks. Lumpy is now going to, for a reason I didn't understand. I don't get it. He's gonna watch an instructional video on how to rebuild his mini transmitter. You kind of just have to make the jump
that the stormtroopers wrecked it and now he's trying to fix it. I guess. This is gonna be another comedy bit from Harvey Corman. This is really just a bunch of physical comedy. It's the worst instructional video ever because the person giving it slowly... He's a robot. He's a robot who slowly shuts down.
He's like malfunctioning. Why would you publish this video? If you took this video, it's not live, right? It's not a live video, right? He's watching a video, like if we went on YouTube to be like, how do I fix my dishwasher? And the one that you're watching is broken. It shorts out as you watch it. Yes, the robot instructor keeps shorting out. Why would you post it? Why wouldn't you get your robot in order before you posted the video? Don't know. Okay, but Harvey Corman does some really funny
physical comedy here. He does, he does. Now on the TV, I'm not sure why, but we're transmitted to Tatooine. We're at Bea Arthur's bar, Acmeena. Acmeena is played by B. Arthur. She runs this bar. She's tasked with managing the bar.
It's very busy. And now we have another character played by Harvey Corman. His name is Krellman. He has six fingers. And he drinks liquid by pouring liquid into the top of his head. He's gonna come over and he's gonna order a drink.
And I just really love Bea Arthur in this scene and I thought we should hear it. She's not taken any of his BS. What'll it be? Hello, Admina. Okay, we'll do it your way. Hello, now we'll do it my way. What'll it be? Hello, at me, huh? Okay, we'll do it your way. Hello. Now we'll do it my way. What'll it be?
Can we talk? Well, of course we can talk. We are talking. You're not ordering, I'm not pouring. We are not drinking. We are talking. I'm moving this to make room for a drink so that next time I say, what'll it be, and you tell me, I can put it right there. Doesn't matter. Give me any of it. I'll have one of those. I'm like she's the Joe Bennett of the Star Wars special.
She is. She's like, she's like, fine, we'll do it your way. Hello. Now we'll do it my way. What do you have? Exactly. Well, you know, I read that Bea Arthur's performance by all the critics at the time was singled out as a highlight of this holiday special. It was the highlight for me. This whole section. And this was all directed. Her whole section, and this was all directed, her whole section, she's about to sing, was directed by the first director, and I guess there are some rumors
that the shoot was 24 hours. My gosh. It was a crazy, crazy shoot day. I saw in an interview that Bea Arthur said she was cast as Actmina thanks to her friendship with Ken and Mitzi Welch, two of the show's producers. They also wrote the song,
这次拍摄长达24个小时。天哪。这绝对是一场疯狂至极的拍摄。我在一次采访中看到，贝娅·亚瑟说她能饰演阿特米娜，多亏了她和该剧制片人肯和米茨·韦尔奇的交情。他们还创作了这首歌，
"'Goodnight But Not Goodbye'." Which is the song that she's gonna sing in a second. Bea Arthur's commitment to the reality of the scene is really incredible. She is so fantastic. These Imperial guards are gonna come on the screen and they're gonna impose a curfew. Everyone has to leave the bar. Yeah, she said, guys, we're closing, they're closing to impose a curfew. Everyone has to leave the bar.
《晚安但不是永别》。这就是她一会儿要唱的歌。贝娅·亚瑟对场景真实感的投入真的很惊人。她太棒了。这些帝国冲锋队将出现在屏幕上，他们将实施宵禁。每个人都必须离开酒吧。是的，她说，伙计们，我们要打烊了，他们要打烊来实施宵禁。每个人都必须离开酒吧。
Yeah, she said, guys, we're closing. They're closing me down. You got to leave. But everyone saw the Imperial Guard come on the screen and impose this curfew. It's not like she took a phone call in the back. No. They pop up on a screen like they do.
是的，她说，伙计们，我们要打烊了。他们要关掉我的店了。你们得离开。但每个人都看到帝国冲锋队出现在屏幕上并实施了宵禁。这可不是她在后面接了个电话。不。他们像往常一样突然出现在屏幕上。
But no one will leave. They don't care. Why? Why won't they leave? I don't know. Why is she the only person afraid of this curfew? She's like begging them, you guys, you got to go. She's like, I'll give you one more round of drinks and I'm going to sing you a song.
但没有人肯离开。他们根本不在乎。为什么？为什么他们不肯离开？我不知道。为什么她是唯一一个害怕这个宵禁的人？她就像在恳求他们，伙计们，你们得走了。她说，我再请你们喝一杯，然后我给你们唱首歌。
And then you got to go. You got to leave. She should have put on the holiday special. You know what? She didn't have it yet. She didn't have it yet. She didn't know. Let me tell you a little bit about Bea Arthur. She was an actress, a comedian, and a singer. She began her career on stage where she won a Tony for playing Vera in Mame.
然后你们就得走了。你们必须离开。她本该放一下那个假日特辑的。你知道吗？她当时还没看过呢。她当时还没看过。她根本不知道。让我向你们简单介绍一下贝娅·亚瑟。她是一位女演员、喜剧演员和歌手。她的职业生涯始于舞台，曾因在《玛姆》中饰演维拉而荣获托尼奖。
So she was really a famous stage actress, musical theater star. By the time she did this special, she was very well known for being in the comedy series All in the Family and Maude, for which she won an Emmy Award. The holiday special was pre Golden Girls though. Here's a fun fact about Bea Arthur she has received the third most Emmy Award nominations with nine. Do you know who's received the most? Lucille Ball? No. Julia Louis-Dreyfus. Oh my goodness. Has been nominated 11 times. Mary Tyler Moore has been nominated 10 and Bea Arthur has been nominated 9.
所以她真的是一位著名的舞台剧演员、音乐剧明星。在她出演这个特辑的时候，她已经因出演喜剧系列《一家人》和《莫德》而广为人知，并凭后者获得了艾美奖。不过这个假日特辑是在《黄金女郎》之前拍摄的。关于贝娅·亚瑟，有一个有趣的冷知识：她获得了9次艾美奖提名，提名次数位居第三。你知道谁获得的提名最多吗？露西尔·鲍尔？不是。朱莉娅·路易斯-德利法斯。哦天哪。她获得了11次提名。玛丽·泰勒·摩尔获得了10次，而贝娅·亚瑟获得了9次。
Like real chops in this special everyone. Yeah like serious amazing talent showed up for this thing. Well she does eventually get everyone to leave. Mm-hmm. And one other fun fact about this scene is that some of the same aliens that we saw in the cantina in Star Wars are in the cantina again, including the band. Yes, I clocked that. Yeah, do you know the band's name?
各位，这个特辑里的演员阵容可以说是功底扎实。是的，真正了不起的顶级人才都来参加这个节目了。好吧，她最终确实让所有人都离开了。嗯哼。关于这个场景的另一个趣事是，我们在《星球大战》坎蒂娜酒吧里看到的一些外星人这次又出现在了坎蒂娜酒吧里，包括那个乐队。是的，我注意到了。是的，你知道乐队的名字吗？
No, I don't. OK. Figrin De'an and the modal nodes. Again, very similar to your... To Billy... What is it? I thought it was Betsy Belly Welly or something. Yeah, I'm telling you, maybe you and George Lucas, same brain.
不，我不知道。好吧。菲格林·丹和模态节点乐队。同样，这非常类似于你的……致比利……叫什么来着？我还以为是贝西·贝利·韦利什么的。是的，我跟你说，也许你和乔治·卢卡斯拥有同一个大脑。
Yeah. We're really good at naming things. Uh-huh to sound like snuffeluckers. I know. Flunky lookies. All right back at the Wookiee house we hear an announcement the Imperial guards are being told to return to base return to base but are they are they being told that or is it a trick from lumpumpy who got his little device working? We don't know. Again, there's just so much keeping up with the Imperial soldiers.
对。我们在起名字方面真的很在行。嗯哼，听起来就像格鲁弗怪。我知道。傻里傻气。好了，回到伍基人的房子，我们听到了一条广播：帝国卫兵被告知返回基地，返回基地——但他们真的是被这样告知的吗？还是伦皮捣鼓出他的小设备后搞的恶作剧？我们不知道。话说回来，要跟上帝国士兵的动向实在是太难了。
There's so many announcements. I would just have announcement fatigue. Well the stormtrooper goes upstairs and catches Lumpy on his device. He takes it and he smashes it and he chases him downstairs and all of a sudden guess who walks in the door? Han and Chewbacca! They made it! But the Imperials are still present. Chewbacca immediately runs to protect Lumpy. Han confronts this whole situation and he kills the stormtrooper by tricking him into falling off the balcony. This is
广播实在是太多了。我简直要患上广播疲劳症了。好吧，暴风兵走上楼去，抓住了正在玩设备的伦皮。他夺过设备把它砸碎了，然后一路追着伦皮下楼，突然你猜谁走进了门？韩和楚巴卡！他们成功了！但帝国士兵仍然在场。楚巴卡立刻冲过去保护伦皮。韩直面整个局面，他通过诱使暴风兵从阳台上摔下去，杀死了这个暴风兵。这大概
probably why maybe they established how high up they were. Yeah. It's a very, very short fight. So all of this has been leading up to possibly one of the shortest fights I've ever seen in a movie. It's like two punches and a fake and then the guy's off the railing. Sometimes it's over. Sometimes that's all it takes.. Sometimes that's all it takes.
就是为什么他们之前要交代他们所在的位置有多高吧。对。这是一场非常非常短暂的战斗。所以这一切都是为了铺垫这场我这辈子在电影里见过的最短的战斗之一。就像是两记重拳加一个假动作，然后那家伙就掉出栏杆了。有时战斗就是这么快结束。有时只需要这样就够了。。有时只需要这样就够了。
I guess that's all it takes. The Wookiees embrace each other and then there's this... Ange, what is happening between Chewie and his wife? What was that? I don't know. First of all... It's like they're... They come together like they're gonna kiss. Yeah, but...
我想这就够了。伍基人拥抱在一起，然后发生了这一幕……昂热，楚伊和他的妻子之间到底在干什么？刚才那是什么？我不知道。首先……他们看起来……他们凑到一起，好像要接吻。对，但是……
But they don't kiss, they just sort of breathe in each other's faces. Yeah. Is it, was I meant to feel that as, what is it? Is it longing? Is it, is she mad? Is she like, I'm still kind of grumpy because you. No, it looked tender. It looked tender.
但他们没有接吻，只是有点在互相呼吸对方的面部气息。对。这是，我是说我应该作何感受，这是什么？是思念吗？是，她在生气吗？她是在想，我其实还是有点生你的气，因为你。不，看起来很温柔。看起来很温柔。
I don't exactly. Anyone back there, did you, what was your take on the chewy mala embrace? We've lost them. Please hold. They've left. Yeah, they just kind of breathe in each other's mouths for a minute. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
我不太确定。后面的各位，你们有谁，你们对楚伊和马拉的拥抱有什么看法？我们失去他们了。请稍候。他们离开了。对，他们只是对着彼此的嘴呼吸了一分钟。对。对。对。
They don't ever kiss or maybe that's- Do Wookiees not kiss? Maybe that's their form of kissing. No, Wookiees kiss. Wookiees gotta kiss and like, I don't know, Mala's been making that dinner, worried about him and that's all she gets. I like how quickly you guys were like,, they kiss let me tell you no Cassie My thing was that I thought Mala was like giving him like a cold shoulder a little bit like he came in to kiss But like he could tell she was still a little pissed. Yeah
他们根本没有接吻，或者也许那是——伍基人难道不接吻吗？也许那是他们的接吻方式。不，伍基人会接吻的。伍基人肯定得接吻，而且，我不知道，马拉一直在做晚饭，为他担心，结果她得到的就只有这个。我喜欢你们刚才那种斩钉截铁的语气，他们接吻了，听我说，不，卡西，我的看法是，马拉当时有点像在给他冷脸，就像他走过来想亲吻，但她能看出她其实还是有点生气。对
Like that, I don't know. He's got a really, you know winter back later tonight. I guess he does I love that you're writing backstory for it. You know, the one thing that really got me is just, you know, how Han is like, hey, you know, you guys are like family to me, you know. And then I'm sure in the stage direction, it said Mala looks at Han with adoration or something like that. But if you zoom in on Mala's face, the look is so crazy. She's like, the look is so crazy. Yeah. Anyway, okay.
就像那样，我不知道。他有个真的很，你知道，今晚晚些时候要过冬。我想他是有的。我喜欢你为它编写背景故事。你知道，真正让我感到意外的是，韩是怎么说的，嘿，你知道的，你们对我来说就像家人一样，你知道。然后我敢肯定，在舞台指导中会写着“马拉深情地看着韩”之类的话。但如果你放大马拉的脸，那个表情实在是太疯狂了。她就像是，那个表情太疯狂了。好吧，好吧。
They don't make a lot of different facial expressions. There's not a lot. Well, Han is going to leave. He's off. He's like, bye. He's got to go. Le'ez. Killed that guy. Where's he going for life? I don't know. We don't know. We'll see him later. Harrison Ford just looked happy to exit stage right. But no sooner is the family reunited than another Imperial officer appears on the screen. So many announcements. Now this is an alert. There's a missing stormtrooper. They've already discovered that this stormtrooper is missing. And this is why I think that they can't see you, because then Sean Dan is like, I got this.
他们的面部表情不多。真的没几个。好吧，韩要离开了。他要走了。他一副，再见的样子。他得走了。里兹。杀了那个家伙。他要去哪里讨生活？我不知道。我们不知道。我们以后会看到他的。哈里森·福特看起来只是很高兴能从右侧舞台退场。然而，这个家庭刚团聚没多久，另一个帝国军官就出现在了屏幕上。通告实在是太多了。现在这是一个警报。有一个失踪的暴风兵。他们已经发现这个暴风兵失踪了。这就是为什么我认为他们认不出你，因为接着肖恩·丹就说，这事交给我。
He puts in his identification. He's like, he robbed me and went off to the forest. And they're like, thank you very much. We'll go send out a search party. Case closed. Done. Is it though? Are they just leaving this stormtroopers body at the bottom of this tree thing? Where does that go? Also, how do you get up there? Is there an elevator? How did you get on the
他输入了自己的身份识别码。他说，他抢劫了我然后逃进森林里去了。他们就说，非常感谢。我们会派搜救队去的。结案。搞定。真的是这样吗？他们难道就把这个暴风兵的尸体扔在这棵大树底部不管了吗？那尸体去哪了？还有，你是怎么上去的？有电梯吗？你是怎么到达这个东西的
front porch of this thing? It's just it's built around a tree really high up. Like do you zip line in? How do you get to the balcony to the front door. Like, do you zip line in? How do you get to the balcony to the front door? Lady, you didn't zoom in? No, is there a bridge? There's an escalator. You're messing with me. Could you imagine that?
正门门廊的？它只是建在一棵树周围非常高的位置。比如说，你是坐滑索进去的吗？你是怎么去到通往正门的阳台的？女士，你没有放大画面吗？不对，那里有桥吗？有自动扶梯。你在逗我玩吧。你能想象那种画面吗？
It was like, dee dee dee dee, little escalator. What though, seriously, are they gonna bury this? They're just like, oh, we tricked them, like what? There's a lot of things you've gotta just make a mental jump for. Okay. These are two of them. How do you get into the tree house?
就像是，嘀嘀嘀嘀，小型自动扶梯。不过说真的，他们打算把这具尸体埋了谱吗？他们就这么，哦，我们把他们骗过去了，诸如此类的？有很多地方你只能全凭脑洞去硬圆。好吧。这就是其中的两处。你是怎么进到树屋里去的？
Yeah. What happened to the body? Okay, well, with the danger now past, Chewbacca's family prepares to attend the Life Day Festival. There's these gold glowing orbs and they're wearing red robes. They kind of look like they're in a church choir.
对。尸体怎么处理了？好吧，既然危险已经过去，楚巴卡的家人准备去参加生命日庆典。那里有一些散发着金色光芒的光球，他们穿着红色的长袍。他们看起来有点像教堂唱诗班的成员。
And somehow they, are they teleported to this tree of life ceremony? I think so. I'll have you know in the Star Wars, the Life Day Cookbook, it's not just food recipes. There are also instructions on how to decorate and dress for the holiday. For life day? For life day, that's right. So you can make a life day orb if you'd like. Here is how you're going to do it. like, here is how you're going to do it. You are going to buy 12 clear glass ornaments,
而且不知怎么的，他们被传送到这个生命之树的仪式上了吗？我想是的。我得告诉你们，在《星球大战》生命日食谱里，不只有食物食谱。里面还有关于如何为节日进行装饰和穿搭的说明。为了生命日？为了生命日，没错。所以如果你愿意的话，你可以制作一个生命日光球。具体做法如下。就像是，具体做法如下。你需要购买12个透明玻璃饰品，
white glass paint, and 12 balloon lights. And basically, pour glass paint into a paper bowl, hold the ornament by the top, dip it in the paint about a third of the way up, let it dry, and then when it's dry, put a balloon light inside. The end. Or would you like to make a life day robe? Can I just order one for my church? Nope, here's how you make it. You're gonna need two yards of red fabric, scissors, and two yards of red ribbon and cut diagonally.
白色玻璃漆，以及12个气球灯。基本上，把玻璃漆倒进纸碗里，捏着饰品的顶部，把它浸入漆中大约三分之一的高度，让它晾干，等干透后，把一个气球灯放进里面。大功告成。或者你想制作一件生命日长袍？我可以直接为我的教堂订购一件吗？不，这是制作方法。你需要两码红色的布料，剪刀，以及两码红丝带，然后斜着剪。
And that's it? That's it? Yes, measure the fabric to the desired length of the robe, cut a hole in the top, put your head through it, and then tie a ribbon around your waist. I'm not joking. That's it. Come on. This is what you do like if you want to be a ghost at Halloween, but you didn't get your costume in time,
就这样？这就完了？是的，根据长袍所需的长度量好布料，在顶部剪个洞，把头穿过去，然后在腰间系上一条丝带。我没开玩笑。就这样。得了吧。这就像如果你想在万圣节装扮成鬼魂，但又没能及时准备好服装，
so you just cut a hole in a pillowcase for your kid. This did not need a page in a book. No. This did not. You know what that is? What? Fluff. That's some fluff at the end of the book. That's some fluff. Yeah.
所以你只好在枕套上给你的孩子剪个洞一样。这根本不需要在书里占一整页。对。这真的不需要。你知道那是什么吗？什么？水分。那是书末尾凑字数的水分。那是水分。对。
Take us to the end of this special, Ange. Tell us how it ends. Well, I sure will. So everybody pretty much is all gathered together. There's a lot of folks in robes. Han Solo's there, Princess Leia. Luke Skywalker, C3PO, R2-D2, they're all there. Everybody's there.
带我们走向这个特辑的尾声吧，昂热。告诉我们它是怎么收尾的。好，我当然会的。所以基本上大家都聚集到了一起。有很多人都穿着长袍。韩·索罗也在那儿，还有莱娅公主。卢克·天行者，C-3PO，R2-D2，他们都在那儿。所有人都到齐了。
And Princess Leia has a pretty big speech and then goes into song. I think we should hear it. This holiday is yours, but we all share with you the hope that this day brings us closer to freedom and to harmony and to peace. No matter how different we appear, we're all the same in our struggle against the powers of evil and darkness. I hope that this day will always be a day of joy in which we can reconfirm our dedication and our courage and more than anything else, our love for one another. Here's the song, it's called.
然后莱娅公主发表了一场挺长的演讲，接着就开始唱歌了。我想我们应该听听看。这个节日是属于你们的，但我们与你们共同分享这个节日带给我们的希望，它让我们更接近自由、和谐与和平。无论我们的外表有多么不同，在反抗邪恶与黑暗力量的斗争中，我们都是一样的。我希望这一天永远是一个充满欢乐的日子，在这一天，我们可以重申我们的奉献和勇气，最重要的是，重申我们彼此之间的爱。歌来了，歌名叫作。
This is the promise of the tree of life. Life Day. We celebrate a day of peace. This reminds me so much of how I try to sing good at church. Ha ha ha. Yeah. I love Carrie Fisher. It's got a little bit of that for me though. Yeah. of how I try to sing good at church. Ah, ah, ah. Yeah. I love Carrie Fisher.
这就是生命之树的承诺。生命日。我们庆祝一个和平的日子。这让我想起我在教堂里努力唱好歌的样子。哈哈哈哈。对。我爱凯丽·费雪。不过对我来说，这歌声里确实有一点那种感觉。哈哈。关于我在教堂里努力唱好歌的样子。啊，啊，啊。对。我爱凯丽·费雪。
It's got a little bit of that for me, though. Yeah. Incidentally, you're hearing it now. This is set to the main title music for Star Wars by John Williams. Yes, it starts to come in there. Mm-hmm. That takes us through the darkness.
不过对我来说，这歌声里确实有一点那种感觉。对。顺便说一句，你们现在听到的这段音乐。这是约翰·威廉姆斯为《星球大战》创作的主题曲。是的，音乐开始切入进来了。嗯哼。这段音乐带我们穿过黑暗。
As she sings this, everyone slowly files out. Everyone in their robes that they cut a hole in and tied a ribbon around their waist, they're all filing out, and the camera pushes in on Chewbacca's face. He's kind of looking off in the distance, and we see a montage of scenes from the first Star Wars movie,
在她唱歌的同时，大家开始缓缓离场。所有人都穿着他们剪了个洞并在腰间系了丝带的长袍，他们全都鱼贯而出，镜头推向楚巴卡的脸。他有些若有所思地望着远方，接着我们看到了第一部《星球大战》电影中的一系列蒙太奇镜头，
and then it comes back to Chewbacca and his family and they're sitting down for dinner with the gold orbs in the center of their table they bow their heads as if to pray and the credits roll. Yeah there you have it everybody everybody. The Star Wars Holiday Special. Yeah. Thank you, Cassie. Yeah, Cassie. You are no longer allowed to write into dear office, ladies.
然后镜头切回楚巴卡和他的家人，他们正坐在桌子旁吃晚饭，桌子中央摆着金色的光球，他们低头祈祷，接着字幕滚动。好了，大家看，这就是全部了。星战假日特辑。对。谢谢你，卡西。对，卡西。你再也没有资格写信给“亲爱的办公室女士们”了。
I just want you to know you've been banned. Oh, OK. I want to know what your review of it. How many stars out of 10? Zero? Zero stars? Maybe one star for Be Arthur. Be Arthur. OK. BeArthur gets a star.
我只是想让你知道你被禁言了。哦，好吧。我想知道你的评价如何。10分满分能给几星？零分？零星？也许给贝娅·亚瑟一颗星吧。贝娅·亚瑟。好吧。贝娅·亚瑟得一颗星。
IMDB rates it at 2.2 out of 10. Yeah. Hmm. Generous. You know what? BeArthur gets a star for me and so does that first stormtrooper that says, I hate fish. So that's 2. He gets a 1 and a half star.
IMDB给出的评分是2.2分（满分10分）。对。嗯。真慷慨。你知道吗？贝娅·亚瑟对我来说值一颗星，那个说“我讨厌鱼”的暴风兵也值一颗星。所以一共是2颗星。他能得一星半。
Well maybe he gets a star. Here's what I think it is. Bea Arthur gets a star. Harvey Corman. Oh yes. Three characters. Yes he gets a star. He gets a star and then a half a star for the stormtrooper who doesn't like fish. There's our rating. Two and a half stars. And Jenna can I ask do you still consider yourself a Star Wars fan? Well I never considered myself a fan. I feel like that. This didn't turn the tides for you?
好吧，也许他能得一颗星。我是这么觉得的。贝娅·亚瑟一颗星。哈维·科曼。哦，对了。三个角色。是的，他一颗星。他一颗星，然后那个不喜欢鱼的暴风兵半颗星。这就是我们的评分。两星半。珍娜，我可以问一下吗？你还认为自己是《星球大战》的粉丝吗？嗯，我从来没认为自己是粉丝。我觉得……
No. It didn't help you. It did not turn me into a Star Wars fan. Ainsley, have you ever seen Star Wars ever? Not until 2019, I think. I saw the first two. OK. So you're like me.
这并没有扭转你对它的看法吗？没有。它没能帮到你。它没有把我变成《星球大战》的粉丝。艾恩斯利，你以前看过《星球大战》吗？直到2019年左右才看。我看过前两部。好吧。所以你跟我一样。
I have no idea what happened. As an adult, yeah. And I did like them. I liked those three, but I'm stopping. I don't need to see any more of the world, but I really did enjoy Star Wars, Empire Strikes Back, and Return of the Jedi. But that is, I'm done.
我完全不知道发生了什么。作为成年人看的，对。而且我确实挺喜欢的。我喜欢那三部，但我到此为止了。我不需要看这个世界的更多内容了，但我真的很喜欢《星球大战》、《帝国反击战》和《绝地归来》。但也就这样了，我结束了。
And now I've seen this. I will watch all of them. This is my least favorite in the fandom, but I will watch all of them. This is my least favorite in the fandom, but I will watch them all. Well, a big thank you to Ainsley for joining us today for this recording. And thank you so much for your outline. For watching it, we're sorry.
而现在我看过这个了。我会把它们全看完的。这是我在粉丝圈里最不喜欢的一部，但我会把它看完的。这是我在粉丝圈里最不喜欢的一部，但我会全部看完的。好吧，非常感谢艾恩斯利今天加入我们的录制。非常感谢你做的提纲。谢谢你观看了它，我们感到很抱歉。
But we had to have you here with us to bear witness to this moment. And we feel like as a gift, you should be the one to take home the Star Wars Life Day Cookbook. I am so honored and I will take it. Thank you. Please make one of the robes and show it to us someday. Yes.
但我们必须让你和我们在一起见证这个时刻。我们觉得作为一份礼物，你应该把《星球大战生命日食谱》带回家。我深感荣幸，我会收下的。谢谢。请做一件长袍，改天给我们展示一下吧。好的。
Okay. Well, everyone, if you have an idea for an upcoming Office Ladies 6.0 episode, we'd love to hear from you. And if your name is Cassie, sorry, do not send in. Angela is going to post a link to our Dear Office Ladies mailbag in the Office Ladies pod stories today. And remember, it can really be any topic,
好吧，各位，如果你对即将播出的《办公室女士》6.0版本有什么点子，我们很期待听到你的声音。如果你的名字叫卡西，抱歉，请不要投稿。安吉拉今天将在《办公室女士》播客故事中发布指向我们的“亲爱的办公室女士”收件箱的链接。记住，什么话题都可以，
just what do you wanna hear us talk about? Please, though, can I have a break from fantasy sci-fi? I'm begging you. Can we make Angela watch a horror movie? No, I don't want to watch a horror movie. I hate horror movies. Maybe. No.
只要告诉我们你想听我们聊什么。不过拜求了，能让我从奇幻科幻题材里解脱一下吗？我求求你们了。我们能让安吉拉看一部恐怖电影吗？不，我不想看恐怖电影。我讨厌恐怖电影。也许吧。不。
Write in and let us know. And please join us next Wednesday for our interview with Kathy Bates. Oh my gosh, we were so excited. We'll see you then. This sherbert and stew are such a disgusting combo. It's coming back on me in a gross gross way. I drink my whole drink.
写信告诉我们吧。请加入我们下周三与凯西·贝茨的访谈。哦天哪，我们太兴奋了。我们到时候见。这果汁冰糕和炖菜的搭配真是太恶心了。它正以一种恶心至极的方式涌上来。我把整杯饮料都喝了。
Yeah I feel weird. I feel gross. I think we should end on that. Yeah. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins.
对，我觉得怪怪的。我觉得很恶心。我想我们就在这里结束吧。好的。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）旗下的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡皮树》。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。